stéphane dauger qui est chef du service
réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré à paris
bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous votre réaction à ces tensions
ces échauffourées ces heurts entre
certains manifestants certains qui ont
un profit de radis radical et les forces
de l'ordre
bonjour madame je n'ai pas de réaction
particulière
j'ai dû quitter la manifestation des
soignants pour aller à un jury de thèse
vers 15h et je découvre les images en
même temps vous je suis vraiment très
triste de ce qui se passe ça n'a pas
grand chose à voir avec les soignants je
remarque juste que quand je suis arrivé
dans le cortège des collègues qui
étaient arrivés avant - disait que les
forces de l'ordre avaient provoqué un
petit peu à la sortie du métro
j'étais très étonné de ça j'ose espérer
que ce n'est pas ça mais apparemment les
images que je vois en même temps que
vous ne sont pas de cet ordre là des
gens sont venus pour en découdre je peux
vous garantir que ce ne sont pas les
soignants du coup c'est vraiment
dommageable sur image à bhl pour l'image
que ça va donner de nos manifestations
qui étaient pacifiques et vous venez de
le signaler qu'ils étaient extrêmement
nombreux surtout territoire apparemment
vous nous disiez à l'instant que vous
avez eu des échos des informations selon
lesquelles les forces de l'ordre
auraient provoqué des manifestants fa la
sortie du nom à l'arrivée à la
manifestation les forces de l'ordre
semblaient déjà rendu je n'ai rien dit
et je n'étais pas l'avis de ses stations
déjà plusieurs plusieurs heures je ne
peux pas vous dire plus que ça
effectivement sans doute que les
policiers s'attendaient à des
débordements
certains de mes collègues ont signifié
que l arrivée à la manifestation il
avait vu que les policiers étaient
tendues voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai dit
je n'ai rien dit d'autre je ne suis plus
à la manifestation des policiers
manquent d'eau des policiers tendions on
a bien compris sur cette journée de
mobilisation qui se déroule en plein c
ur de la santé oms et c'était une
journée d'action à paris en tout cas et
sur tout le territoire importante pour
les personnels soignants pour vous tous
oh qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant
l'avenir de cette manifestation à paris
parce que ça se déroule aussi en
province donc on va pas non plus noircir
le tableau mais vous pensez que la vos
revendications elles vont être entendus
que le message il va passer tout le même
on va écouter je ne sais pas un homme ça
n'a pas grand chose à voir ce qui a été
fait avant le travail qui a été fait
entre autres par le collectif danger je
suis un des membres est extrêmement
important nous avons participé aux
seniors avec l'avant et la police est
retenue c'est pas uniquement des
débordements qui ont eu lieu en ce
moment mais l'ensemble des personnels et
des citoyens des usagers qui sont venus
nous soutenir
donc les villes de france devant tous
les hôpitaux quel que soit qu'ils soient
privés ou ni sur tout le territoire je
pense que c'est quand même ça le message
et j'espère j'ose espérer que marne on
va se servir de ces affrontements le
champ de manifestation uniquement à
paris pour remettre en cause de notre la
mobilisation surtout la motivation des
personnels pour avoir ça le service et
ça l'objectif
certainement pas autre revendication
nous voulons nous voyons c'est la seule
motivation de des gens qui étaient très
très nombreux devant le ministère de la
santé
le jour alors vous parlez du ségur de la
santé on sait que pour beaucoup de
personnel soignant ça n'avance pas assez
vite et on voit que dans la rue c'est
difficile de faire entendre sa voix
parce que c'est compliqué de manifester
sans qu'il y ait aujourd'hui des
débordements des heures comment on fait
maintenir ses revendications et faire
avancer les choses
le dialogue avec ce gouvernement de la
manifestation était un des acteurs
unitaire les syndicats ont appelé à
venir les collectifs mais aussi et
jusqu'à ses débordements qu encore une
fois je sens que vous la balle de la
manifestation se passait très bien je
pense que on a eu confirmation de la
volonté des usagers d'essence et de
défendre l'obtient d'aidé forme de
système de santé pour le remettre au
niveau de ce dont nous avons besoin
d'autres actions sont en cours comme
vous le savez sans doute qu'on l'a sans
doute oublié mais le conseil économique
social et environnemental eux
travaillent d'arrache-pied pour proposer
aussi à part pris de concertation
nationale des points forts pour réformer
le système dont l'hôpital public une
grande conférence organisée le 2 juillet
d'autres propositions ont été faites
tout au long du ségur pour l'instant
n'ont entendu de j'espère que ça va
changer aussi
et donc on a quand même beaucoup de
levier pour montrer notre bonne volonté
et la zone volonté s'est avancé
construire un hôpital de demain
basée essentiellement sur une
revalorisation des salaires l'arrêt de
la fermeture des lits une gestion de
bonne qualité adaptés aux besoins du
territoire avec l'ensemble des soignants
et non soignants c'est l'unique
participe aux décisions adaptées à la
population ou en ce moment qui devrait
remettre en cause ses motivations
merci à vous stéphane de g